so that was age 15
now age seven oh she's wait that's my
rating
almost 2 400.
okay i'm kind of scared
oh she's playing at the strength of an
international master
uh-oh but maybe she should
be saying uh-oh because i'm also
international master
am i ready i was born ready
okay i'm white this game
there's only one thing to do
oh do i play a queen's gambit
or do i play a london
the queen's gambit is enthralling let's
make the game enthralling
let's go queen's gambit against the one
and only beth harmon
have to use her weapon against her she's
playing a slav defense
let's develop a knight
let's develop another knight oh
she's playing what is this she's just
playing a semi-slave
i should play like i should really play
my own preparation
so she's basically declining the gambit
which makes me a little bit sad
and she's just creating like some
illuminati so i'm going to play e3
bishop g5 is like the main
like complex line which i don't want to
mess with
i know she has kind of an attacking
style so
i just want to be solid queen c2
b3 i played this many years ago
this was part of my repertoire
actually she she already made like some
inaccuracy like bishop d6 is uh
is usually what people do
[Music]
um play bishop d3
oh she's being she's being clever
also thank you denny's samil subbing a
tier one
yeah she's trying to make the game kind
of spicy
um
i'm tempted to play c5 here
it just shuts down the whole queen side
and the idea with c5 is actually kind of
interesting
where i want to castle queen side
because it's hard for black to actually
open any files
and then i want to play like some crazy
kingside
pawn storm let's do this
i'm thinking knight knight e2
oh she is opening a file
maybe my king will just stay in the
center
or maybe i'll castle play king b1 knight
c1 and just be extra safe
and bishop a6 is coming
[Music]
i can't really stop it though
yeah this is going to be a tough game i
could maybe play knight g3
keeping the option to castle king's side
let's do this
okay that's what i like to see because
now i can play queen e2 preventing
bishop a6
and she's really trying to annoy me on
the queen side
let's play i gotta do it i i
i have aggressive instincts too
okay we're trading
i should probably castle kingside or
maybe i'll
i'll leave the king in the center
uh
yeah i really want to win so i can say i
beat her with the queen's gambit
but it's going to take a lot of work
i mean the the setup looks nice
but she's i mean she's controlling all
these squares
and going fishing probably won't
accomplish much
i think it makes sense to start with
this move
because at some point black's going to
do this and i'll want to
eventually have a rook come to a1 so
this should be the most flexible
okay queen c7 may be preparing rook a8
okay let's castle
because the a file is kind of important
and i think we're going to end up
trading
oh i just realized
i just realized something really
important this pawn is weak
this pawn is just a long-term weakness
so if we if we trade
rooks and queens
i can eventually put the bishop on d2
put the knight on c2 win the pawn
and then hopefully convert the end game
and hopefully she won't see that far
ahead
so let's start by trying to trade rooks
and now i'm going to try and trade
queens
how to do this
my first impression was queen b2 and now
i'm thinking bishop b2
because queen a2 queen here
and then i can play knight d2 defend
upon queen b1 queen a1
so we're going to try and play this very
slow methodically and positionally
just have to watch out for like tactical
tricks
but the pawn is always defended
okay so that's a trick if i if i allow
this i lose a bishop
so i could take
i could also play knight e1
man this is serious
it's taking a lot of mental energy
i could play queen here too wait this is
almost forcing a queen trade wait no
wait
if i play this queen b3 i win the bishop
i guess it's queen a5
but then i'm fine i'm fine with that
yeah let's do this
yes let's go okay so
i think this is just a completely
winning endgame but i have to be careful
not to blunder
so the plan is what i said earlier to
attack the pawn
to win the pawn to push this pawn make a
pass pawn
and not blunder
okay there goes your pawn
[Music]
what are you trying to do to me
[Music]
okay so i'm up upon
oh what does this move i play h5 maybe
so she's just trying to set up like a
fortress basically i'm also trying to
tickle my h-pawn
so h5 g5 knight e1
and some idea like f3
i think it makes sense
okay f3 can't be played right away what
does this move
okay let's train he's going to win the
back the pawn but that's okay
as long as i hold on to the extra pawn
[Music]
and now i want to get rid of this bishop
okay oh it's almost a fork but not quite
because
knight takes e5
that's so close i can play knight f1
so here's what i want to do i want to
play f3 remove the knight and then fork
the king
the pawn but if i play f3 too soon i
lose this pawn
[Music]
and i don't want to
i don't want to have my pawn chain just
crippled
so
i think the plan is to over defend f
over defend e3 so i can play f3
i am looking at the possibility of
playing f3
letting black take and then trying to
trap the knight
but then knight c2
[Music]
there's also this move king f7
[Music]
i know bishop c7 is coming too
oh i have an idea okay this move
actually serves two purposes
not only does it over defend e3 but it
prepares the maneuver
here here and then guaranteed fork
so let's do it
oh but it's not so simple
now black's gonna be controlling the
square
a lot of times maybe i have this idea in
bishop
e1 f3 bishop g3
that's so positional
ah i can't play f3 anymore
i played b4 maybe so b4
maybe threatening b5 to play c6 knight
b8 c7
wait a minute i can play knight b4 oh
then knight b8
and she always has a move
i'm i'm on the verge of like
basically winning also thinking about
this and then this
because the bishop just wants to be on
this diagonal
[Music]
i think that's the way to go
if i can get the bishop here i prevent
knight b8 and then knight b4 will win
the pawn
wait a minute okay there's a few
approaches here
this is probably simplest i attack the
pawn if black defends i
attack the knight
man i swallowed the t the wrong
i way to wash it down with more tea okay
um so she's being
she's making simple threats let's play
g3
okay let's go easy win time
just have to push some baby
oh oh she's trying everything she's
throwing all her pawns at me
[Music]
but i'm not afraid
just like eminem used to say
okay b5 time oh
i'm kind of afraid
and that was actually kind of
resourceful
i mean i'm on i'm on the verge of
queening i just don't want to lose the
base of my
my beautiful pawn chain
so if i play f3
f3 takes takes e2
[Music]
i can take with check move the knight
the bishop covers the square
i think it's all okay
yeah we're gonna trade wait let's
actually
let's push first wait a minute
i could just play king f1 king e2
i don't want to mess with e2
she is being tricky though
i'll play bishop c7 first
she's being tricky but i'm being very
safe
how does this move
i might have to mate with bishop at
night eventually
that could be kind of annoying um
but also instructive
okay bishop always covers the square
um
how to do this
play this move thanks for subbing oh
laundrom
or laundry m gifting subs thanks so much
okay i don't mind that
okay i really don't mind that
let's go
okay all i have to do is not stalemate
wait how do i not steal me
oh my pleasure okay
let's go oh she saw what i did there
that was hard not to see it
let's go i i beat i beat beth harmon
with the queen's gambit
with the name of her own netflix series
let's go that was a good sequel too
because the previous game was a kings
gambit
and that was actually kind of
instructive like this uh
the structure from the opening because
even from like from this position
the fact that this pawn was weak it
allowed me to win
much much later on oh thanks so much
akira lane
gifting 10 subs really appreciate that
so if this goes on youtube i hope you
guys learned a thing or two
[Music]
about long-term thinking and i should
know like obviously i'm playing an
engine
so this was like a prime position
to have against an engine where the
engine
didn't realize that this was just like a
long-term
weakness that even though i don't win it
immediately
i can win it eventually and it was
enough to win the game
um so this will probably go on youtube
this will probably be like a whole
series
so i don't know what part this will be
in the series